taking a comics character from the
printed page to the big screen isn't as
easy as you might think in guardians of
the galaxy's Gamora was no exception
just ask Charlie Wynne former head of
visual development at Marvel Studios and
take a look at some of the designs that
didn't make the cut before 2014 there's
a good chance that if you set the phrase
guardians of the galaxy to your average
moviegoer their reaction would be pretty
similar across the board and that's
exactly what Charlie Wynn was banking on
when he started adapting the characters
from Marvel Comics long history of
spacefaring weirdos for guardians of the
galaxy nobody knew what guardians was
it's very niche and so what was great
was it also left it so that we could do
a lot with it if you upset some of the
hardcore fans maybe it's okay because
there's not as many of them you know
what it did do was allowed for a lot of
exploration to create a Marvel Space
Odyssey the freedom to experiment is
probably why the screen version of
Gamora as well as the concept art Wynne
created has very little in common with
the comic-book depictions that have
appeared in the pages of Marvel Comics
over the years some comic book
characters are relatively easy to adapt
to the screen at least when it comes to
knowing what to keep and what to junk
Batman spider-man and Wonder Woman may
have outlandish comic-book outfits but
they also feature iconic details that
make them recognizable Captain America
without his shield and super outfit
suddenly becomes a guy who's a little
too excited every July 4th and Wolverine
without his claws is just your hairy
uncle Lou back with another case of
molson
Gamora by contrast doesn't really have
any features that truly define her look
in the minds of comic book fans and that
presented a major design challenge for
the team where do you begin for when it
started with archetypes but it didn't
end there as an archetype she's in this
the lone assassin that functions on her
own and you start there but then I think
you really need to add in those elements
that she needs to service while this
concept art doesn't seem too out there
it also doesn't really communicate many
ideas about who Gamora is or what she
wants her needs
the Moroz adventuring gear seems like
she's ready for battle but we can't tell
much about her character
on that according to win an essential
part of the design process comes not
simply from picking the right look for
the character in fact it's quite the
opposite
we're trying to write some kind of story
paint an image one of the things that
you do first is you figure out what your
limits are the farthest you're gonna go
where where are you gonna start with and
so it's your contrast what is your
contrast that idea of establishing the
contrast is clearly at play in this
concept art where we see Gomorrah
looking a whole lot different from any
of her depictions either on screen or on
the page when led the team about as far
away as they could from the comics just
to see how far they could stretch the
idea of Gomorrah before it broke down
with her purple skin weirdly tapered
ears and her dimpled mostly bald skull
these versions of Gomorrah definitely
have a passing resemblance to her
adopted dad Thanos but she feels a lot
more unsettling and creepy than you
might expect for a big-budget Marvel
movie hero as when directed his team to
continue exploring different looks for
gamora's on-screen appearance they
started moving in interesting new
directions case in point this light
purple version of Gamora whose skin
features some of the intricate markings
that would become a part of the final
design signature look more importantly
however is the expression on her face
which seems to express a lot more of
what might be going on inside her head
when told us that Kevin Feige was very
interested in this particular look for
Gamora but ultimately they decided it
was more difficult to pull off the
intricate tech on her face than it was
worth as gamora's look evolved her
character began to emerge in the concept
art Charlie Wynne created in these
images we see two similar settings and
scenarios for the character Gamora in a
crowded sci-fi locale surrounded by
aliens and other outerspace weirdness
but you can see that even though the
Gamora in this image is undoubtedly cool
and on the hunt this other one that
looks lost in thought seems to have a
lot more in common with the version of
the character we got in guardians of the
galaxy
you know she's this super assassin
that's from a different alien race
connected with vanos we're onin nebula
so she's got again she's got her own
dysfunctional family to worry about she
has to have
vulnerabilities even just in her look
they can't just go for this ninja right
that's all covered and everything
there's a part of her that is exposed
and I think we're vulnerable paints it a
little bit better also that she needs to
be a character that you can relate to
because she's gonna have that kind of
connection with Peter quill you know
later on while this image still doesn't
look at ton like the finalized look for
Gamora her purple skin is a dead
giveaway it still manages to express
more about the character in the world of
guardians of the galaxy than any of the
previous versions seen Gamora at the bar
with her Cheshire Cat grin seems to make
her look dangerous and deadly but also
ready to get drunk thanks to the forearm
barkeep right behind her what's most
important is that this version of Gamora
has tons of personality that's the most
important part when designing meaningful
characters that audiences will spend a
lot of time with how do you make her
feel like the character that you would
really feel for but there's something
happens to considering how fans reacted
when she died at the hands of fan else
in Avengers infinity war it goes without
saying that when and the team he led at
Marvel Studios completely succeeded in
answering that particular question check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more exclusive looper videos
with Charlie Wynn about the creation of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Applause]
[Music]